we'll see i appreciate you uh tapping in
man i've been a big fan
and i have a i'm a big bernie guy too
so yeah i miss bernie's uh man
i take every i take every loss like
super personally
not because of like wins and losses but
i know
the people that i'm fighting for
actually are fighting for everyday
people and i know that when when bernie
loses
or when somebody else that i'm fighting
for loses people suffer as a result of
that
and so he to me
if you went into a lab and made
a candidate designed for a pandemic
bernie would come out of that like he
was made for this moment
like i so desperately wish he was
president man
and uh he i think he would have mopped
the floor with trump man yeah it's
interesting i guess we'll just dive
right into it because like i'm
i'm very passionate about bernie and um
i was
when he lost in 2016 and there was that
moment at the um
at the convention where his brother was
crying that [ __ ] oh yeah
well you know his brother loves him man
and
and what people you know i worked with
bernie on
on this for this campaign you know
bernie
bernie was deeply hesitant to tell
his own origin story and what his
brother knew
in that moment was man they grew up
rough man
like his his family narrowly escaped the
holocaust
most of bernie's family died in the
holocaust
and they grew up dirt poor in the middle
of brooklyn
in a community of really of holocaust
survivors
and uh they both of his parents his
mother and his father died when he was
in college
and it it changed bernie in a huge way
man and when his parents died is when he
threw
himself into the civil rights movement
and um
his brother knows all of that better
than me or you
or anybody and so to see uh to see him
his brother was
was deeply touched it was a it was a
special moment for bernie who
who doesn't show a lot of his emotions
on his sleeves
you're right he doesn't yeah and to see
him do that
it was deep man